US forces say they've destroyed drones
launched by yemen-based houthis over the
Red Sea earlier the armed group said it
was responsible for attacking a
transport ship the Hui say it's part of
a response to Israel's war on Gaza
Transport company MSC Mediterranean
shipping says its vessel had been
targeted it says it alerted what it
called a coalition task force warship
and was told that the commercial vessel
should take evasive manuvers the crew
were unharmed the US says it's creating
a maritime coalition to fend off houi Ta
on
shipping in support of the oppressed
Palestinian people who continue to
suffer from killings destruction Siege
and starvation the naval forces of the
yemeni Armed Forces with the help of God
carried out a targeted operation against
the commercial ship MSC United using
suitable Naval missiles the targeting of
the ship came after its crew refused for
the third time the warning and repeated
warning messages from the naval forces
the yemeni Armed Forces also carried out
a military operation with a number of
drones against military Targets in the
Israeli Port City of Alat we're get
across to Russell s who's joining us
from jibuti so Russell talk us through
this latest attack and of course what
kind of impact that's happening having
on shipping in the
area well the the attacks are
intensified here so the US Central
Command saying that the US assets
military Assets in the region they have
shut down 12 oneway attack drones three
anti-ship ballistic missiles and two
land attack uh cruise missiles in the
southern Red Sea uh that were fired by
huis over the period of a 10 hours so on
Tuesday so this is quite huge number and
so far since October 17th there has been
nearly 100 drones operated by houis that
have been shut down in the region houis
they have attacked since then they have
attacked uh more than 20 uh one uh ships
that were passing through the Red Sea
and of course as a result the maritime
trade here is is dramatically uh
disrupted the experts here the
authorities here they're saying that
that the number of the ships passing
through Babel mandab have declined went
down dropped by almost 35% and now
behind me very close to the port of
Djibouti you can see that dozens of the
the the the shipping uh vessels here are
stranded they have been stuck here since
days they're waiting for the clearance
and many of them do not know when they
are going to get it when the road is
going to be safe to continue their their
Journey so huies here are Now setting
new rules so they're saying that every
ship that is passing through Babel MB
needs to assure them they had that they
have nothing to do with Israel they're
not not going to Israeli ports that they
are not living from the Israeli ports
and that they are not owned by uh by
Israelis so as I said that the business
here is quite disrupted and it's h
having also Global impact as well so on
Tuesday the oil price serves by 3% it is
the highest in this months and and
several of international shipping
companies they have suspended their
operations now the Germany heag lloid is
saying that today they are going to have
discussion how to proceed from now on
just earlier and almost a week ago they
said that they are going to reoo at
least 25 ships around Africa but now
they're trying to operate the USA is
pressuring over the international
shipping companies a lot however the
situation is here is quite challenging
Russell thank you very much indeed
Russell s talking to us from
jibou